thank you everyone I hope you can hear
me this is on yes correct okay first I'm
going to talk about my path to
entrepreneurship I when I was an
undergrad at Berkeley I wasn't really
thinking that could ever be a founder I
didn't see founders like me I didn't
hear about entrepreneurship
although entrepreneurship has been very
key in almost my family my mom is an
entrepreneur I'm small business owner
yet I didn't see myself to actually be
on this side
other things I will share with you are
my journey on building a typicai being a
Latina founder two days let latina equal
payday and Latinas only make fifty cents
per day one dollar that men do and so we
really and we're severely underfunded as
well not only in Silicon Valley but
across all the attack and
entrepreneurship ecosystems around the
world so what is a typical we basically
power analytics for teams to understand
really how they're doing on diversity
and we do things outside of self
reporting because not everyone will
self-report I'll go into it but we
really believe that this is the most key
and pressing business issue out there
inclusion belonging diversity employee
activism ethical tech all of those
things I will touch upon during my chat
today and obviously I will leave some
time at the end so that week if you have
any QA you'd be more than happy to ask
me some questions actually this is
really funny I will start here typica
was born on this campus ironically
exactly five years ago I was asked by
USA Today to do a closed event at
Stanford Law to talk about this pressing
issue of diversity inclusion with
leaders of Facebook and Google VPS of
diversity and inclusion and the Reverend
Jesse Jackson I'm Stanford Law Professor
Richard Thompson to come and speak on
this issue a background about me and
I'll stay here I usually do have a slide
I grew up I am an immigrant and I grew
up in Redwood City so I I was a child I
tell people that my culture and my birth
place is in Mexico but my hometown is
Redwood City I live three blocks away
from your mom when I was probably her
age I didn't think I would ever live
near my mom in my 30s but here I am and
Redwood City is my home I grew up there
before a lot of the changes that you're
seeing in around the Bay Area I tell
people that I knew Mountain View before
there was a googol and that the only
reason I would go there to go to
shoreline to go see the fugees play a
concert it's important for me to
acknowledge that even as a child that
grew up in the Bay Area I never saw
myself being an entrepreneur my mom was
a house cleaner and was also a nanny to
a lot of tech executives during the 90s
yet I didn't think that I could play
part of that ecosystem but here I am and
I'm very feeling very grateful and
fortunate but also I know that I have
fought a long way to come here I was
also I cannot be emphasized that
although there's certain identities to
my intersectional existence I was also
an undocumented child so everything that
I embody and I might actually at is
because I grew up in Silicon Valley
whether it was a curse or a blessing I
grew up here I worked here in high
school actually I worked here at
Stanford the reason I didn't end up
coming here is because I didn't want my
mom to show up with a pot of beans at
the dorm and I thought hey let me look
at other ways that I could be near her
but still I'm work I had my first
internship at the at the age of 17
before I started college at
hewlett-packard right on page Mill Road
and I don't see again no one that looked
at me and once I started my first intro
to engineering class it was right away
that I decided I didn't want to be in
this industry ironically because of how
I grew up here Here I am I also think
this is this picture is really important
because I believe I'm the only founder
that had their mother their future
investors future clients their friends
be present when I spoke about why I
looked at Facebook I said you have the
largest facial recognition that data
said in the world
the best probably brilliant data
scientist why are you saying that you
can't get more women into your
engineering roles or you can't find more
people of color either brown or black
people to Google intern are your company
and the same for who I held them
accountable that they had this talent
but they weren't really tapping it into
actually creating more inclusive
workplaces they didn't answer me so I
said okay well I was supposed to travel
around the world and I decided to
postpone my travels to fund this company
I was just explaining to my friend two
weeks ago that this has been my longest
job in tech five years in counting but
it is when you're a founder or an
entrepreneur you're passionate enough
you keep going I've worked on a lot of
tech companies another thing that is
very interesting to me has been that I
founded an enterprise startup even
thought my most of my most of my career
has been in consumer web but also I sit
on a lot of the boards that you probably
hear of like Anita board on the
diversity Council the women of color
council they put on Grace Hopper on
code.org I believe I just got an email
two for their annual dinner so for me
it's really important not to just talk
about it build a company around it but
actually do something and contribute
back why this matters to me and to
everybody
everything here is changing weather is a
demographic I was just reading about an
app built by women house cleaners in New
York for themselves where they actually
it's part of the gig economy they're
actually they deploy all of their apps
to make sure that there's a livable
wages to all the house to all the sort
of domestic our house cleaners in New
York so they will people will use
technology to unionize to really make
sure that they live in in a world that
is just and unfair more women are
entering the workforce as we all
No ten years ago I wouldn't have
imagined a room like this
I was also wouldn't have imagined like
the changes I haven't made by all of the
women that have contributed some of them
I love naove here but otherwise people a
lot of women that have paved the way so
that everybody feels that they have a
fair chance and also we have to think
about all of those different paths where
I find really interested in is that a
lot of my clients understand it but it's
not necessarily a way to think it's good
it's ethical we should invest in diverse
and inclusion it's a business imperative
four hundred billion dollars are lost in
PR nightmares I mean how many times do
you hear about someone what a famous
rapper walked into to Sephora and was
discriminated against or began so walked
into Reebok meeting and there weren't
any people of color so she walked out so
a lot of it is related to PR but
employee attrition dissatisfied
shareholders and we see all of the sort
of movements that happen a couple years
ago by women in tech are still affecting
companies that have gone public and
they're still not doing well that their
culture is not has not really healed
from those things so we really I do
believe that this is not necessarily it
feels good that this is an impetus
imperative for the future a lot of this
data is fragmented anecdotal and broken
everybody will just say hey I ran a
report I feel like this is enough and we
tell people that's not enough if you're
centralizing all your other data I'm the
number one field right now in sort of in
data science within a business
organizations actually people analytics
70% of all companies now have people
analytics where when I started at a
typical five years ago it was less than
five percent so they're looking at how
people are being paid what the benefits
are the engagement how they're being
hired who's being hired
so people analytics is something that is
very very profitable and I was being
used
that being said who's building these
tools and so we have to ask ourselves
that and with a typical eyes what we're
aiming to do I also believe that the
future of the workforce and not just on
race and gender or
the other or age it is a non-binary
workforce how are we adapting to how
people identify themselves or don't
identify themselves I spoke here at a
Forbes CIO summit where CEOs of like
corporations both financial and media
companies like Sony Pictures heard me
speak time and time again that a CIOs
role is to actually gather more
information around their people they're
going to the CIOs world ten years ago
was probably about information and IT
but in the future it may be around what
what information and what that are you
gathering for your own workforce the
market is quite big I did this didn't go
the market is quite big if people don't
know like visual analytics I say it's
Queen because I'm a big feminist but
they dare all this is where it as
tableau was acquired by Salesforce were
I believe 18 billion earlier this year
and look or by Google so a lot of data
data and visualizations are happening
right now around how to make business
businesses adapt to what is needed from
their consumers to the key performance
metrics any of that stuff for me I just
focus on people as I said people
analytics is growing I give the stats
because I think it's important to know
that this may change and by the time
some of you graduate or some of you are
in the workforce midway through your
career it could be three times as that
this didn't exist when I started at
typica you imagine me being a founder
going up Sand Hill Road or talking to
investors saying I want to build a
platform based on inclusive ethical and
responsible a diversity and analytics
this is five years ago they thought we
don't get what you're building but those
are the things that we we have to adapt
really quickly and we have to be part of
the conversation especially women
especially women of color I put this
picture I did not put the logos of this
man but as you can see I have received
about 3.8 million dollars in funding
I've raised the largest seed round in
the silicum in the history of Silicon
Valley by Allah solo latina founder I
have not raised more
I have raised about the same in the five
years a typical has been around in this
space where I'm at and I know Sarah I
spoke here at also she works in HR Tech
and their recruiting platform we
integrate with her product but in the
space that we're at I have seen men in
the past year we see more than 300
million dollars in funding I've received
one point four percent of that even
though I've been in the market now a lot
of these tools are saying they're
building inclusion into their tools into
how employees are happy or all this
stuff but it's really important to think
that like the bandwagon is there that
intensity needs to be there
does it hurt yes being a female friend
is not easy especially when a lot of
other founders are talking about
inclusion and putting it into their own
tools and raising 70 80 million dollars
off it but we're the only ones that are
focused on this I tell people you can
hire a lot of people analysts and if
this might be a project for them but for
us it's not a project this is our
livelihood and this is what we are very
passionate about what is it typical so
typical we have a platform as you can
tell them a product manager because I
built it three products are built on API
the diversity intelligence which is
proprietary and also how to mitigate the
biases there are in in recruiting I've
started out with a typical thinking like
it's the recruiters they need to they
have biases and we realize that data
shows that it's not the recruiters that
there's different ways to understand
where biases come from but you first
need to give them the data the diverse
intelligence was actually something that
leaders asked me I want to see reports
based upon how people are moving
throughout the funnel we want to see who
came in did this event really pay off
and so we built that as well and then
one of her clients Netflix and I put
decided that hey we already we don't
need a different product can you build
an API so that we can just use your
technology and layer it on internally
nor dashboards so we did how are we
different and this can be and you can
ask me how is this ethical not ethical
whether they some of their legal so we
actually I decided
a lot of at in recruiting you'll see
what is your race or ethnicity or your
gender and that's the EEOC the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission report
that is voluntary you don't have to
answer it
some people answer it other people don't
some people answer one aspect of their
identity I may answer that hey I'm
latina but I mean an answer that one
woman it depends but there's a lot of
data gap but people are making goals
around this or thirty percent if you
feel that thirty percent at the top of
the funnel then ninety percent then 70
percent of that like you don't know and
you're making goals or the business are
making goals I also decided I know
exactly how automation and
recommendation systems work and what
aspects of your identity are being taken
obviously data and privacy we were just
talking the professor and I on the
importance of that and privacy so Howard
tipica ended up getting a ninety six
percent accuracy rate on gender or
training said it's very diverse
we take government data everything from
the ELC to census so it's a really
important for 2020 I'm gonna volunteer
for the census as well son says location
universities and the university
demographics so the Stanford probably
looked very different ten years ago than
it does it will look like in 2020 and
then we learn from it we use her own ml
models to actually to actually think
okay if someone's name louder and the
last name is Gomez most likely be latina
and a Latina names usually end with
being attributed to females but in in
Southeast Asian like persona is one of
her visiting scholars and he is Indian
so how do we make sure our models are
here are ethical they're very localized
in there and they're able to were able
to validate them we do the same with
race I got my masters in the social
construction of race so when people say
can you internalize it is to the UK we
cannot because then we we need to look
at census that in
UK we need to look about what people
identify as and that is very newest
nuance so we don't do that we've done
this here based upon what my knowledge
is of the racial component of the United
States how people are self identifying
so yes we're 96% accurate in inferring
gender and ninety-one percent and what
percent on top of the funnel a lot of
people think that it's based just on
names that's a foundation but that's
only about 67 percent accurate the res
we've really worked on and over the past
five years here are some rules that you
can see that we look at it on the data
science on how long it takes to hire for
tech roles in how many days and what
this analysis was early on you see some
trends and then you see some differences
that are coming across on whether it's
the market that people take more time to
hire or less so we do this type of
analysis if you go to our blog we just
did one on referrals and it was very
interesting women did really well in
smaller teams when they were referred by
anyone but as long as soon as they were
referred into a larger organization they
actually did not do well into tech so we
did a lot of referrals we did referrals
on on black and brown candidates and how
they get into the funnel and then we
also did as I said on what we called the
bamboo doorway we saw that Asians in
general had a harder time being hired
and through the referral system and we
did the same for operations for gender
and so we look at all of this
information for as visualisations are
really important that's the way we say
yes that data is you can have
data-driven but you have to have data
purposeful my goal in vision really is
in general with a typica is to foster
growth and innovation through Dea
I was the year diversity equity and
inclusion so I've to become a brand and
trusted for attraction for attracting
talent and retaining it but also to
protect businesses from liabilities we I
do have I talked to many lawyers
asked me is this legal and I say yes
because we don't say we don't pay point
to specific people we use aggregate
information like tens of thousands not
millions of applicants another my first
angel investor was an employment lawyer
you will see time and time again I think
LinkedIn just published something
yesterday or the day before that a lot
of these tools are recommending
applicants or recommending candidates
they will be audited in a court one day
because who built this recommendation
systems for example in age some people
like myself when I got into the
workforce
maybe my major didn't exist or now it's
the equivalent to something else right
maybe statistics now it is data science
but if the recommendation system says
we're only looking for data scientist
it's actually been a gist so a lot of
the tools in our space is that are
actually going to and you see this time
again even in consumer you see
recommendation systems I spoke at women
in the world one of the largest or
conferences Oprah opened a stage and
then I was on a stage the next day that
was really amazing but we talked about
automation and artificial intelligence
is going to disproportionately affect
women especially women of color around
the world not just in the United States
because those are the ones our manual it
will also think about ethics facial
recognition for black women obviously
we've seen the studies time and time
again and then finally responsibility
even if my AI even in my drone is a
responsible AI tool what if someone gets
hands and it gets in the hands of the
wrong people I just read I know the
founder and CEO of ringg Jamie I met him
once but I just read that ring that the
police can actually ask if anything
happens a crime occurs within two block
radius
the police can actually keep that
information from ring for 45 days even
if you had nothing to do or your home
to do with the crime that was committed
so discussing this implications of
access to data privacy artificial
intelligence is really important to
understand that people cost and
liabilities I will end there but I want
to just take a step back and put my
email here in case anyone doesn't want
to go into the Q&A for me I want to talk
I spoke a lot about my product about my
company about the space that I'm in I
will not speak really quickly and I
don't like having as many slides there
because you can never really understand
what it is to be a founder nowadays it
is hard
everybody is always talking about the
recession's coming debian said I feel
it's the greatest equalizer as it
relates to building something out of
pure passion I never saw myself on the
stage I never saw myself as a founder
but my friend he built this very awesome
oven smart oven and what he wants is
people eating healthier and and making
sure that food doesn't go to West waste
and so when we go through and he is does
not anything look like me or is or is
within this circle of like what my
activism is but we're all founders we
all started building for some ways and
something that we wanted we went through
the fundraising process we went through
entrepreneurship for whatever reason I
always like to tell this story
mine has a lot of purpose because I'm
very passionate about it but everybody
has passion even when you don't know or
you read there might be some founders
out there like I just solved a business
problem and that's okay too but I
remember I talked to this entrepreneur
from South America one time and he was
really passionate about having access to
air fresheners that he can control
remotely and I was like okay but we
talked and I realized that this was
based upon some sensitivities that his
wife had things that he really wants
that smell is actually really important
when you go go into your home after work
and he did a lot of studies on that but
he was so passionate about it and so I
honestly
believe that entrepreneurship is
something that I hope anyone here
whether you you are you don't may not
become an entrepreneur IBK I started
working at startups right after college
so I've always been part of smaller
startups that grew when I was at Twitter
there were less than 50 employees I was
the first Latina there and then I ended
up heading localization and left when
there were almost 2,500 people so but I
saw what entrepreneurship was through
all these early experiences and so for
me it's really important to talk about
importance and just how amazing it is
right before I came here I would looked
on my phone and I probably got one like
if not I can't divulge a lot but it's
not one of the most important emails for
my career as a founder and for my team
and for my investors I also chose wisely
my investors they're very and my board
members all entrepreneurs will be faced
with taking the money from certain
people that you may not agree with or
backgrounds or firms that didn't do so
well on being respectful or are not as
supportive but I really thought long and
hard
I turned down some I turn down money
from people that I just couldn't really
imagine to be in my board so those are
some of the learnings that I had but I
don't take away that it is sad to me
that Susilo Carell who was actually in
there undergrad here and she went
through YC that she had to make her own
list of how many Latinas have gone over
1 million dollars in funding and so far
we have 25 that we found across the
United States and that statistics you're
not keep the same so definitely the
struggles there the but we all have the
Solidarity of whether we build something
out of passion or we're in the same
circle of who we are to come here
finally to me it when people come and I
don't know who here is local but when
people come from from other places to
Silicon Valley I explained to them why
this is so important to me my family
still lives here I am the face of like a
lot of you
I was at Cooper cafe and I invited my
god I mean my coffee to come is hear me
speak I said but it'll be a long line
because it's really important that the
communities that that serve as the
communities that I'm a part of are
actually are seen so they I tell people
that my nieces and Elena Natalya
they can't be where they can't see and
so if we're me it's important to speak
at events like this it's important to
actually talk about the activism that I
do not only through being a founder and
through the tools and building but also
through just sheer existence to be to
move forward and so for that I will
leave it open there is about 20 minutes
or 19 minutes for Q&A any questions that
you may have please feel free there's a
lot of questions you can ask me anything
up you show a lot of graphs about race
and gender and you touched on ageism the
bias is there so one of the things I did
talk about was what we'd said if like
someone that graduated 20 years ago in
statistics and now it's really just data
science to be quite honest but they have
a degree that they machine learning so
we did some of that we also have looked
at we actually looked at something very
interesting we looked at in the summary
section where people say over 10 years
of experience just 10 years but imagine
if you're 21 or 22 you're graduated but
the time you have 10 years of experience
are gonna be 31 32 that's not that's
actually quite young that's not even
ageism but we notice that they drop off
of calling them with calling those
individuals was really high and then
when we noticed where people put if even
the length of the resume or where they
put their education and if they put like
two or three more degrees I have to well
have technically like four because I did
double undergrad and double masters but
if they listed more than degrees like
they would seem that there were two
overqualified
them it would be tied back to age so
we've done that work it's really
interesting to see how we can really
push forward Network we're still a small
start-up so definitely I want to talk
about that another thing that we've
discussed is looking at ways that where
people's zip codes are located because
you know San Francisco it's mostly young
people they said there's more dogs than
kids in San Francisco so there might be
ageism in in locations and so we're
looking at all that on a kind of semi
related pronouns on resumes and social
media and Linkedin are a whole new thing
I didn't see this five years ago so
pronouns now on binary and non-binary
folks are really coming up project
include the nonprofit that Ellen power
runs actually did a survey among
startups and 5% of all the tech
workforce identifies as non-binary so
we're doing different type definitely I
feel like the older I get the more I'm
very passionate about this I also talk
about looking at data points that are
meaningful to the workforce so I
explained this to a very very powerful
woman I mean she flies private jets with
a very famous CEO and say I was in a
meeting with her and I say as I get
older I still want my female
counterparts to have access to and my
male counterparts to have access to
paternity leave maternity leave
fertility thoughtfulness on what matters
on reproduction and like family but as I
get older I mean want a benefit on how
to walk my mom through retirement or
most women end up taking care of their
mothers and so like how can we support
women as they're getting older in the
workforce for their with their parents
and so those are all aspects that I
think about on ageism ones like that
even the benefits sometimes are ageist
towards not including where people are
in the stage of their lives
so when you heard college as a how did
you think through some of the problems
we either ask you something yes so I
will repeat that question so as I
entered my career into tech after I
graduated how did I really think about
the ethical or the social
responsibilities of working at this
companies and did I have a support
system that's an excellent question I
worked as a contractor the little red
badge at YouTube when I started off
there
they had just been acquired by Google
and then content moderators were like
the most depressed people and you can
see the same with now other tools they
would tell me some of the videos that
they would see and I would purposely not
walk in that direction and there were
only 300 employees I look back and I
look bad about I'm also part of this
other like I don't have enough time but
I'm also part of this other organization
called build tech we trust where we saw
a radicalization online not being held
accountable by the tech companies by the
content that they're providing and so
after the mass shootings on around white
supremacy and radicalization a bunch of
women of color CEOs here in the Bay Area
we came and we build that but bill tech
with trust as a coalition and then we
even submitted questions to Congress
when Mark Zuckerberg went there a couple
of weeks ago on their questions around
the ethics going back to your question
if I could go back I would have taken
more attics courses I'm in college and
thinking about what I'm building to
complement my more technical or my more
social degrees
then I worked at Twitter and the first
time a dictator started tweeting on
Twitter was Google Chavez which is a
dictator of Venezuela and I was in
charge of Twitter in espanol so I went
to the general counsel there and I said
should we have a policy on how leaders
or dictators to tweet on this platform
if it threatens the the citizens lives
or or like does but it was kind of like
a passing thought do I wake up and think
about it yes especially given nowadays
so I do believe that I did not have that
system and so maybe this is my way of
atonement of working for all the tech
companies to try to reverse a little bit
I think after their 2016 elections one
of my colleagues at Twitter tweeted out
what have we done and I just remember
that tweet and I was crying and then my
partner worked early at Facebook and so
he was he has been he yeah he worked at
through the API on Facebook so he knows
everything that happened there on data
and the coverage analytics stuff so I
think we're all everyone in this
industry is like really torn on how we
can make a change and hold ourselves
accountable I always tell people I have
a love-hate relationship with the tech
but I love the industry enough to want
to change in it and stick around for a
while so thanks for that question yes
before C including military veterans
great how do I foresee including
military veterans I have I was actually
on the board of a veteran organization I
had to step away when once I started and
I build another company operation code
and we did at the study the same study
but what we will realize that veterans
actually self-report themselves on very
high that we don't need models to to
include them into the process but we
need more is understanding transferable
skills so we neutralize a taxonomy of
skills among veterans to know like if
you're a program manager in the Navy how
does it trance
into something similar so we neutralized
that we didn't need to really fill in
the gaps um on reporting I wish I had
more funding and were and I large your
team I would definitely have like little
subsets of tackling age tackling veteran
inclusion also most likely you know
LGBTQA and disabilities more into a
product yes the statistic that you
shared about just there being only 25
Latinos who raise funding is shocking
and what that made me wonder was where
did you find confidence in yourself to
feel like you could do it and how have
you worked through moments where that
was tested so I had a very high profile
job with mostly at Twitter just very
high profile and so annoying a lot of
the early employees there ended up as a
venture capitalist so I thought it would
be easy for me little did I know 2014
Laird I was very idealistic it was I
didn't prepare myself I didn't
understand like Captain Yoos I didn't
understand a lot of things I read a lot
I'm a speed reader how are you how did I
get the confidence I don't think I don't
know if anyone has talked here about
like the valley of despair that founders
go through it's like this valley where
like I can't get out of bed I don't know
what's going to happen I really believe
in this and then you kind of get up I
believe that value of despair for
underrepresented founders fundraising is
really hard anyone fundraising I
remember I was coming back from an event
with a male friend of mine who's a
founder and he's like I hate Sunny Hill
Road coming up here yeah it's that's
experience that people just have I do
believe that it's it was hard but there
were many tears shed that I was telling
that Ravi was one of our investors that
actually gave us a blood line to try to
get more fundraising but it always seems
like it's it's towards the end are your
okay I give up and then something keeps
you going I remember a friend of mine
emailed me and she has a PhD she has a
co-founder who her CTO and said you're
the trifecta of difficulty like you're a
solo female latina founder it was hard
I'd like to share this because I think
it's important and people get shocked
earlier this year I was at a board
meeting and I started getting a headache
and I was like this headache is weird
and I was flying between New York and
here and and I the headache didn't go
away and I'm a board meeting I felt
really weird and then by Sunday my board
meeting was Friday but Friday morning
Sunday I was actually here at the ER
here Stanford and I was diagnose which
we did not then but with a benign tumor
and so I about earlier a couple of
months ago I actually wrote a blog post
that says I survived Silicon Valley and
brain surgery and brain surgery was
easier and it was I have nothing against
Stanford here but I looked where were
their best neurologist and specialist
with what I would get given all this
stuff and I realized that that I CEO and
myself out of that situation like very
quickly got second opinion like within I
got three opinions with the top
neurologists within two days like I was
texting I was everything my mom's like
why are you computer like here at the
hospital but it honestly it was able to
teach me that that if I hadn't been a
founder I don't know if I would have I
probably would have gone into a despair
mode when you're diagnosed with those
things I just like so yeah I definitely
do believe and that being a CEO and a
founder an entrepreneur has shaped the
way I interact with challenges every day
when brain tumors are probably not
everyday challenges so but you know
we're here
anyone else yes I'm not a data person or
a tech person but I'm curiously when
companies are so the question is how
does how do business leaders and
companies actually react to the data and
whether there's a shift in their
behaviors it's different
some people will focus only on one thing
like gender other people will want to
see more detailed information like or a
reporting tool it's just like literally
I pulled the report the other day for a
client I was like this is way too much
data but here it is like it goes to a
granular by source by by location like
by event how do they do it it's it
depends where people want to take that
step but because we learned their
behaviors as well over time our
recommendations are very different when
they start off then when they're at six
months into our client I've seen I've
had conversations with some of our
clients ex and current clients around
getting their lawyers in earlier in case
there's something surfaced that we that
were - was not very capable of doing but
that we're very what I will like is to
be empathetic in their approach is not
like hey you're doing this I can't
believe you guys can't believe what
happened in the last three months it's
much more about acquire the tools that
you need to change we saw a lot of women
withdraw in sales in an organization and
when we actually dived in we realized
that there were that the recruiters were
putting in compensation at the offer
stage but men were actually asked
compensation at the technical screen so
we said you might just want to talk
about compensation in just a set amount
of inclusive
so talk about also questions like
instead of saying hey we have free food
come and work with us and look at our
awesome food think about hey we like to
make sure that our employees are
nourished that means that we are also
very responsible on food waste there's a
woman outside of Atlanta Jasmine crow
who's doing the gritter she is actually
does all about food waste because it
actually saves companies millions of
dollars through tax sort of breaks and
so think about all those inclusion
components that are important to people
nowadays I'm definitely other things
that we're seeing a lot of is employee
activism so now we're asking our clients
to actually ask about what what other
things that that are important to the
candidates earlier on
[Music]
yes definitely so where the bias is
coming on in a hiring process and the
tools so if anyone here either whether
you're a technical not technical if
there's a tool that people are giving
you for example if you're if you're
applying for a business role they might
use a tool like a spreadsheet or
something like that but like that's not
very there might be some biases in the
way that they present those numbers to
different types of groups for technical
a lot of the tools they we tell them to
audit the tools because that's where the
bias is it's the tools at the earlier
stage and it's the people at the later
stage specifically hiring managers so
even when candidates get in and they
interview in a panel if the hiring
manager is asking questions that that
are not very inclusive we see
withdrawals and rejections at a higher
rate it's in recruiters will do too but
we also publish a blog post about again
in data engineering and I'll leave it
with that women with more education and
the same experience as a man were
actually rejected at the application
review so we've worked with those
recruiters and they the reason that it
was a male intention the reason they're
like other two overqualified wedding I
don't want to work here as I won't you
shouldn't make the decision you should
ask the candidates
[Music]
[Applause]